[Music]
you might have noticed that while
fighting as the samurai or sneaking
around as the ghost gin head on a
different set of armor that's because
the armor in this game actually gives
you different mechanical advantages it's
not just the way it looks
it helps accent your chosen playstyle as
you explore the world you'll discover
ohm amore charms they'll give you an
edge in battle but more importantly as
your legend grows you'll develop all new
techniques which transform jinn from a
samurai into the ghost but the thing is
you get to decide how those techniques
evolve and grow over time it's always
worth keeping an eye out for die flowers
find enough of them and you can change
the color of an armor
so not only do you get to choose how
that Ghost gameplay evolves but you can
fine-tune the look as well
[Music]
it wouldn't be a sucker punch game if it
didn't have photo mode and our new photo
mode we have features such as color
grading depth of field so you can focus
on the right objects we have a bunch of
new features that really underline the
motion and movement that's so great
about our game you can control the winds
direction the speed you can change out
the particles to different types of
leaves and fireflies you can even select
a track of music from our original score
that might be a little bit more fitting
so if we ended doing a photo maybe you
actually want to do a video there's
something here for you
here's a few that I've created
[Music]
[Music]